it was like at first you thought oh my  god it's a skit oh my god just wait a  minute there's no punch line wait whoa  it's a punch not a punch line and you're  like oh that's that's really unfortunate  how did you feel about will speed  you know  i would like to more of a straight  apology  to chris you know  that would have been that would have  been great because i mean i thought  will's performance was amazing and i'm  sorry that he  tarnished it with this behavior you know  i mean we all nobody likes to be made  fun of but you got to have a sense of  humor about yourself can't take yourself  that seriously i mean we're just acting  you know let's just relax